coup d'envoi de la tnt de marc à la
télévision numérique terrestre
quatorze chaînes gratuites seront
proposées dont huit nouvelles des
chaînes privées et des chaînes publiques
richard tripots et jean-michel lumière
nous dévoile la nouvelle offre de france
télévisions
[Musique]
france cap c'est la nouvelle chaîne de
france télévisions et c'est grâce à ce
petit boîtier appelé adaptateur qu'elle
arrivera demain sur votre écran de
télévision
elle viendra s'ajouter au programme
généraliste de france 2 à ce nationaux
et régionaux de france 3 et bien sûr aux
débats et documentaire de france 5
france 4 se veut la chaîne publique du
spectacle vivant
elle mise sur la musique avec entre
autres le retour de taratata le cinéma
et les séries européennes et des
retransmissions en direct de grands
festivals un programme conçu avec deux
objectifs clairs aux trentenaires et aux
cadres à à ce public vaste des jeunes
actifs et deuxième objectif pour être
complémentaire des offres de programmes
de france 2 de france 3 de france 5 et
arte
côté france 5 la nouveauté c'est qu'on
ne fermera plus les portes à 19 heures
pour laisser la place à arte les deux
chaînes ont désormais chacune leur canal
et pourront diffuser leurs programmes 24
heures sur 24 sur les ondes de rtl
nous souhaitons garder les mêmes valeurs
qui ont fait notre force dans la journée
c'est à dire d'être une chaîne incarné
par des visages connus du public être
une chaîne lisible et accessible à tout
le monde avec ses quatre chaînes
diffusant sur la tnt france télévisions
devient le premier opérateur de cette
nouvelle technologie
même s'il y a cinq ans son projet
portait sur six chaînes dont une toute
info est une époque effectivement où on
attendait un peu plus de la télévision
publique
là le rôle des opérateurs privés sera
peut-être plus important mais pour moi
l'essentiel était que ouf on l'offre
publique qui actuellement est sur trois
canaux avec arte qui partageons cannes
avec france 5 va passer à 6 quand même
un doublement c'est déjà bien et dans
les prochains mois une nouvelle chaîne
sur la tnt pourrait voir le jour fruit
d'un accord entre france télévisions et
le groupe lagardère
elles seraient consacrés à la
[Musique]